[Musique]
Québec veut encourager les personnes de
65 ans et plus à rester sur le marché du
travail en rendant le RRQ le régime des
rentes plus flexibles explication ce
soir avec Pierre-André Bouchard
Saint-Amand économiste professeur à
l'École nationale d'administration
publique bonsoir bonsoir alors le RQ
d'abord et avant toi allons-y dans
l'ordre l'âge minimal d'accès pour les
gens qui veulent avoir leur rendre
d'hommard à 60 ans ça n'a pas changé
donc on avait eu une proposition en
février du gouvernement de ramener ça à
62 ans donc gagné deux années de travail
des personnes plus âgées sur le marché
du travail mais il y a une levée de
bouclier en voyant quelque sorte une
promesse rompue
par de la part des syndicats et puis le
gouvernement négociation dans le secteur
public a décidé de jouer prudent il
pense toujours que c'est une bonne idée
mais il a décidé de pas le faire ouais
c'est ça donc on passe pas 62 c'est
toujours 60 ans pour l'accès et cela dit
à une pénalité bien sûr sur la rente la
rente normale est à 60 ans et vous
pouvez attendre jusqu'à
pour aller chercher votre 30 là ça va
passer à 72 maintenant 72 alors plus on
attend évidemment plus l'argent qu'on a
mis de côté ou qu'on a épargné à travers
le régime des rentes permet d'augmenter
son montant annuel de rendre versée
alors comme vous le voyez dans le
tableau si on y va à 60 ans vous voyez
que c'est un 836 dollars mais si on se
rend jusqu'à 72 parce qu'on travaille en
plus pendant ces années là on obtient un
montant additionnel en fait qui est plus
élevé la rendre annuelle toutes les
années sera bonifiée par rapport à la
rendre dite normale de 65 ans elle est
maintenue mais évidemment contrepartie
on part des années de retraite alors
c'est des années qu'on est au soleil où
on est au travail donc c'est la
réflexion que chaque personne doit être
le travail vous ensoleille exactement
alors à ce moment-là c'est le meilleur
des deux membres exactement donc est-ce
que c'est une bonne mesure c'est une
mesure qui incite au travail alors si on
y pense dans cette logique là le message
du gouvernement c'est de dire venez nous
aider il y a pénurie de main d'oeuvre on
a besoin de vous alors la question comme
individu est-ce qu'on veut retourner
travailler il y a que vous que moi comme
personne qui peut décider si les
incitatifs envahent la peine cela étant
dit reporter l'âge de retraite sont des
heures travaillées c'est certainement
financièrement avantageux et attention
aux congés de cotisation c'est peut-être
un cadeau empoisonné par leurs hommes
pour les gens qui veulent travailler
au-delà de 65 ans leur propose de ne
plus cotiser donc d'avoir plus d'argent
dans leur poche ça aussi c'est un
encouragement travail c'est un
encouragement au travail mais ça ne
maxise maximise certainement pas
l'épargne et la raison étant que si on
prend congé de cotisation l'employeur
aussi prend congé de cotisation donc
pour être en mesure de d'avoir un gain
financier net de ça faudra en mesure
être en mesure de placer cet argent là
dans quelque chose qui est tellement
avantageux qui qu'on recouvre la peur de
l'employeur dans la cotisation donc pour
ceux et celles qui sont tentés par cette
option là peut-être négocier avec
l'employeur pour aller récupérer cette
partie là parce que l'employeur fait
aussi un congé aussi un con à travers ça
mais donc les gens qui veulent continuer
à travailler parce que beaucoup disaient
j'ai pas beaucoup d'encouragement à
continuer à travailler parce qu'il faut
que je continue à cotiser là il y a
quand même une mesure qui était ajoutée
qui est la protection de la rente
c'est-à-dire que votre rente ne va pas
baisser si vous avez un revenu de
travail certainement une bonne idée donc
l'idée qui est un peu irritante bien sûr
on continue notre cotisations donc
ce qu'on vient de discuter mais aussi
parce que le la rente est calculée sur
les années de salaire gagné sur un
montant moyen si on travaille les
dernières années avec des salaires plus
faibles ça diminuait notre an donc ça
n'existait pas à travailler certainement
en mettant un plafond pardon un plancher
qui limite cet effet là on encourage de
fait à retourner au travail sans
pénalité et donc la protection de la
rendre se fait si votre revenu est plus
faible que la moyenne de vos gains
professionnels de vie exactement c'est
exactement ça ok on a des questions on
va répondre à deux questions du public
juste pour bien comprendre Daniel
Jalbert nous dit ceci je comprends qu'à
la suite des mesures dans le budget la
rente est protégée justement en cas de
salaire inférieur après 65 ans mais
qu'arrive-t-il si le salaire augmente le
travailleur peut-il par choix continuer
de cotiser pour augmenter le montant de
sa rampe alors oui Daniel peut le faire
sans problème c'est la logique de la
réforme en fait du gouvernement c'est
d'insister au travail donc s'il y a des
avantages on veut pas pénaliser le
travailleur ou la travailleuse mais au
contraire faire en sorte qu'il retourne
travailler sans que ça nuise à son
régime de rendre ok parfait autre
question qui nous vient de Claire
carrier qui dit en mai je vais avoir 70
ans et je continue toujours de
travailler je viens de faire mes
demandes pour l'obtention de la pension
de la Sécurité de la vieillesse et pour
le régime des rentes du Québec je n'ai
pas encore reçu de confirmation de leur
part mais les versements devraient
débuter en juin prochain est-ce que les
changements apportés par le budget
peuvent s'appliquer à ma situation
on le souhaite on le souhaite à Clara
l'intention gouvernement le
gouvernemental certainement c'est que
Claire en bénéficie cela étant dit les
mesures budgétaires sont annoncées pour
janvier 2024 alors il y a peut-être une
période d'un an là d'implémentation
administrative qui va faire en sorte que
Claire et repas droit même si c'est
l'intention ça lui coûte rien d'appeler
par contre on sait jamais pour vérifier
pour vérifier ok est-ce que de façon
générale le fait de d'aller chercher sa
rente à 60 ans est une bonne idée je
pense que le gouvernement voulait
surtout encourager les gens à ne pas le
faire mais des gens qui ont besoin de le
faire c'est ça je pense quelques
considérations à pondérer la première en
c'est les besoins immédiats peut-être
que c'est effectivement on a ce point-là
besoin d'argent peut-être que on pense
pas c'est besoins futurs mais assurément
à ce moment-là on se pénalise plus tard
c'est l'histoire traditionnelle la
Cigale et la Fourmi la femme de la
Fontaine il faut en mettre un peu de
côté pour pour la retraite
cela étant dit pour le reste des
personnes qui ont peu de moyens de le
mettre de côté
c'est vraiment la réflexion entre les
années de retraite au soleil versus des
années mieux plus payantes en restant
plus longtemps au travail et c'est ça
qu'il faut évaluer parfait merci
beaucoup merci pour cette
explications en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]